okay so this is absolutely out of
nowhere but can we please take a minute
to appreciate Super Mario bro Z for
those unfamiliar this was an insane fan
animation crossover new ground series
which featured Mario characters and
Sonic characters battling out Dragon
Ball Z style the entire thing was
completely unvoiced other than
occasional lines from their games and
feature some downright sick action
choreography and you know every once in
a while I just like to look back at this
era of the internet before everything
became so monetized and consumer
oriented the wild west era of the
internet was amazing not to say there
aren't still amazing passion projects
out there now but I don't know maybe I'm
just waxing poetic about the old days
and maybe I am just that old man but
there was something really great about
it hold up did he do a reboot in 2016